[Music]
is it just us or is everything so
expensive these days well luckily in the
age of YouTube snapchat and just the
Internet in general anything you want is
just one Pinterest tutorial away do you
want everyone to believe you make the
best cupcakes watch this video to find
out how to do this without even baking
don't forget to like this video and if
you're new here subscribe to our channel
for more videos like this today we will
be taking you through ten of the easiest
and most oddly satisfying DIY projects
that you can do at home pet face clock
do you hate looking at your clock does
it seem to only remind you that you are
late or running out of time alarm clocks
and clocks in general can be a great
source of stress for some people but
this hack had come up with a way to take
the anxiety out of time how by putting
your pets face on the clock what could
be more satisfying than your cute pug or
adorable kitty telling you what time it
is nothing that's what
here's what you do take a photo of your
beloved pet print it and place it onto a
foam board that is at least 1/8 of an
inch thick
next use a knife to cut out the face to
create a 6 to 8 inch wide circle take
out the clock hands from your clock aide
and paint them a fun color now it's time
to put the clock together cut a tiny
hole in the middle of the face and
follow the mounting instructions in the
clock it cut out 4 small paper dots and
place them onto your pets face in the
noon 3 6 and 9 positions and that's it
now the next time you are running late
you can look up at your cute pets face
and know that nothing is as bad as it
seems
gemstones soap bath time is one of the
most important parts of the day what
could be better at the end of a long
stressful day than a nice warm bubble
bath a bubble bath with beautiful
gemstones here's what you'll need
Stephenson crystals soap base clear and
opaque food coloring and silicone caulk
make the base of your molds following
the instructions in the Stevenson
crystal soap base kit spread the batch
that you create between some small jars
to make small molds be sure the
containers can handle high heat after a
few
your mold will be ready next cut off the
amount of soap you will need to fill the
mold and cut it into smaller bits
microwave them for 30 to 45 seconds take
them out and stir to make sure the soap
is liquid now add color use food color
droplets to mix and match the silicone
molds to get the colors you want next
all you have to do is leave the stove to
cool it might be a little tricky the
first few times you do it if the soap
doesn't set around the edges then when
you remove the soap just wash it to get
rid of the liquid soap residue after 2
to 3 uses you shouldn't have this
problem anymore
happy bath time glitter shoes what their
still being no place like home if
Dorothy hadn't had those glittery shoes
no we think not the only way to ensure
that you always make your way home when
you click those heels is to glitterize
your shoes and now thanks to this
tutorial you can here's what you do
find a pair of white shoes that you like
next take your favorite shade of glitter
stop the toe section of your shoes with
something so that it stays sturdy and
doesn't lose shape mix together the
decoupage and glitter concoction that
you have made you can use as much
glitter as you like the more glitter you
use the more solid your coat will be
move in small sections and work the
decoupage over the entire shoe once your
first coat is done let the glitter dry
for a few hours it is very important
that you don't rush this or you will
accidentally brush off your first coat
when you go in to apply the second
repeat the same steps for the second
coat once the glitter is as thick as you
would like it seal everything with a
layer of JQ podge and let it dry
overnight the next morning you will wake
up to beautiful glittery kicks guess who
remember the childhood game guess who
each player pulled a card with a face on
it the object of the game was to guess
the person that was on your opponent's
card you did this by asking questions
like does your person have glasses
do they have brown hair until you were
able to narrow it down to one person
well if you want to add a personalized
twist to the game add in the faces of
your family and friends it's not as hard
as you might think start out by picking
the friends and family members that you
would like to include cut out everyone's
head and add
names to the bottom of their photos
print out three copies of each photo one
for each player and one for the center
pile paint the black of the birch pieces
and attach the faces to the pegs using
double stick tape measure all your pegs
and line them up on the hole glue each
hinge to the peg then screw the hinges
to the board cut your dowel down into
four pieces
glue two down to the front of the board
to hold your card and voila a
personalized game of guess who this is
the perfect gift for a close friend or
family member
light up the room decorating a room can
make a big difference the difference
between a house and a home is just decor
but interior design can get expensive
especially if you like personalized
items so why not make your own this is
what you will need cardboard letters and
string globe lights first pick the word
that you would like to make into your
sign then cut out one side of each of
the cardboard letters with an exacto
knife in the string lighting package the
light bulb should be sitting in a
cardboard tray use the hole in them to
trace openings into the cardboard
letters trace the circles where you want
the light bulbs to go next
use an exacto knife to cut across the
center of each circle making sure the
cut goes from edge to edge turn over the
cardboard letters and poke through to
make the hole larger now you can put the
light bulbs in each hole and screw on
the backing placing the wires in place
inside the cardboard edges these signs
are the perfect way to add some Flair to
any room from the living room to your
bedroom just take a word that fits and
get to creating kinetic foam sand coke
is delicious we all know that but with
all the coke that people consume it'd be
great if you could use those empty coke
bottles for more than just recycling or
trash well we have found one of the most
fun ways to reuse them first you will
need a kinetic stamp kit from pom-pom
toys take a coke bottle and remove the
label next use an exacto knife to cut
the bottle into three separate sections
one at the base of the bottle neck and
one at the bottom of the body of the
bottle next put the cap back on the
bottle scoop your first color of sand
into the section that you're holding
pass the sand down flip the bottle
/ remove the cap and pack a little more
sand in the top now shake the bottle
gently letting the foam slide out of the
bottle it should retain the shape of the
top of the coke bottle next take the
label and place it around the foam and
put the cap on top making your foam look
like the top of a coke bottle repeat the
process with the middle and bottom of
the coke bottle and voila you've got a
foam coke bottle DIY neon slime if you
were born in the 90s then you probably
remember the era of slime and years
after it only got better it doesn't have
to be just any old boring slime you can
make it neon all you need is liquid
starch school glue and food coloring
first mix two parts glue and one part
starch next pour the glue and starch
mixture into a bowl then you can add the
food coloring that you want stir it well
make sure it's completely mixed once it
starts to gel you can mix it with your
hands this is a little easier than with
a spoon if your slime turns out too
liquidy you can add more glue on the
other hand if your slime is too sticky
add starch in the same manner continue
mixing until the consistency is just
right for you storing the supply may be
harder than actually creating it because
blaim dries so fast you need to be a
little particular about where you keep
it Ziploc bags and Tupperware work great
if you make sure to keep them tightly
sealed you can finally enjoy the slime
you wish you had in the 90s
glow-in-the-dark slime now that you know
how to make neon slime let's take it one
step further think of all those nights
where you take the kids or your little
siblings out camping what could make the
experience funner than some
glow-in-the-dark slime to add to your
campfire tales so here's what you will
need two bottles of Elmer's white glue
bottles glow-in-the-dark paint water
neon food coloring for axe and warm
water
simple enough first pour the glue out
and into your bowl fill the bottles of
glue with warm water close them and
shake to remove any excess glue inside
the bottle now pour the watery glue into
the bowl and mix it up with a spoon this
is when it gets fun now you will want to
add the food coloring
- you're glue neon colors are always a
great choice next for in some
glow-in-the-dark paint and stir in
another little Bowl makes half a cup of
warm water with one teaspoon of borax
the water should help dissolve some of
the borax before you add in the glue
mixture once it's dissolved mix the
borax with a glue mixture that you
created with a spoon once it starts to
mix you can use your hands to continue
mixing keep mixing until the slime is
just the consistency you want rain
clouds remember in school when you are
forced to participate in science fairs
the age old volcano experiments were a
dime a dozen but we have found a new
take on experiment that you don't need a
lab to conquer it's called a rain cloud
and here's how you can make it you will
need a glass water a dropper shaving
cream and as always food coloring first
pour water into the glass and making
sure to leave about an inch of the glass
empty at the top slowly add a layer of
shaving cream to the water make sure you
don't add too much because the more you
add the slower this process will go
right now the shaving cream should
resemble clouds next is time for the
food coloring add a few drops of the
food coloring to the top of the shaving
cream the weight of the food coloring
will cause the shaving cream to allow it
through and result in the colorful
rainstorm this project is usually used
to teach small children about the
weather
it is best done outside so the child can
compare the self-made project to the
actual sky funfetti candles don't you
just love walking into someone's house
when they've been baking the house is
full of warm delicious scents of sugar
chocolate and other wonderful treats but
what if you're not the most proficient
Baker are you doomed to have a home that
only smells stale
not with this DIY project trick everyone
with this delicious smelling funfetti
candle all you will need is mason jars
pre wax wicks a hot glue gun corn syrup
rainbow sprinkles soy wax flakes and
cupcakes scented wax cubes first hot
glue a wick attachment to the bottom of
each of your jars then mix two
tablespoons of
syrup with water in a bowl coat the
inside of one of the jars with a mixture
using a paintbrush pour some of the
sprinkles into the jars and roll them
around so that they will stick to the
side add spoonfuls of sprinkles until
the entire jars are covered lay a pencil
across the top of each of the jars and
tape the wicks to them use the double
boiler to melt the wax flakes and three
of the scented cubes next pour the
melted wax into the jar
finally put the jars into the freezer
and let them sit for three to four hours
and you've got deliciously scented
candles that's it for 10 oddly
satisfying DIY projects what did you
think are you going to try to make some
of these at home let us know in the
comments and don't forget to subscribe
to our Channel see you next time
[Music]